Not another Rattata.
So the carrier T-Mobile
is offering a free data, or zero-rated,
deal for the popular Pokémon Go social
game.
Some critics have said that this
violates the FCC's net neutrality rules.
They allege that T-Mobile is somehow
picking winners by choosing to zero-rate
this particular game.
Well, the fact of the matter is that zero-rating and free data are not violations
of the FCC's net neutrality rules.
The FCC looks at zero-rating on a
case-by-case basis,
but if it made a flat-out ban on zero-rating, it would likely violate the First
Amendment and the freedom of speech. But more
than that
T-Mobile is not picking the winners at
all. This is perhaps the most popular video
game of all time. It's been downloaded on more mobile phones than any. They're simply
responding to what their particular
users want and hoping that they can win
new customers by taking advantage of a
marketing opportunity.
People don't value all content the same,
so the idea that every piece of data
should be priced the same doesn't really
make any sense.
If you'd ban zero-rating out of the
gate, you'd have a lot fewer carriers
because they're be very few ways to
differentiate in the marketplace.
What do you think about T-Mobile's
Pokémon Go deal?
Let us know in the comments section
below, and let us know what other
questions you'd like AEI scholars to answer in 60 seconds.